now moving on and the Russian president
says that civilians should be evacuated
from Ukraine's croissant region as
kiev's troops push further south
Vladimir Putin made those comments as he
marked Russia's national day of Unity on
Friday it's his first acknowledgment of
just how volatile the battle for her son
has become Ukrainian forces have been
advancing towards the town now for weeks
the Russian army says more than five
thousand civilians are now being
evacuated every day kiev for its part is
describing those moves as deportations
let's speak to Harry Fawcett he is in
Kiev for us Harry can you talk us
through what's behind the sense of
urgency we're seeing now
well I think a lot of people are looking
for the answer to that question and it's
not really clear at the moment what is
clear is that as you say this is the
first time that Vladimir Putin himself
has made these sorts of comments about
civilian evacuation from her son
something we've been hearing uh from
other military and local installed
Russian government officials uh in this
area which they have annexed and claimed
for themselves and occupied uh what
Putin said was that civilians should be
taken out of the zone of the most
dangerous action and that they should
not suffer uh as a result of the
fighting one of the civilian Russian
installed official officials there on
Thursday was talking about potential
military withdrawal across the danipro
river uh to the side to the Eastern side
where the preponderance of Russian
forces remain so the other side of the
river from the main city of her son
although he seemed to walk that back
somewhat in another interview saying
that he hoped that would not happen as
for the Ukrainian military a
spokesperson for the Ukrainian military
in the south of the country nearby
saying that this could all be a
provocation designed to try to draw
Ukrainian troops into her son and
potentially into bloody street battles
there certainly for all the talk of
withdrawal Ukrainian intelligence has
been talking about reinforcements of
Russian troops inside her son as well so
this is extremely unclear there's been a
push for Hassan that's been going on by
the ukrainians since August partly that
was used
to make it easier for them to to have
advances in the Northeast around the
hakib area but again the focus is very
much on Hassan but there's a news black
out there from the Ukrainian side all of
these competing narratives it's very
difficult to know what precisely is
going on Harry foursome there live for
us in Kiev with all the letters thank
you very much Harry